questions from Amanda in Indiana I'm in
the middle of a divorce and not sure
what to do with my will what do I do
with my will after my divorce is
finalized
especially where my young kids are
involved well you would reset your will
you need a new will anytime there's a
major life change or any time you change
states you would need to set a new will
and so you'd rewrite your will it's
certainly up to you what you put in the
will and who's going to be taking care
of your children in a divorce situation
unless their father is unfit to care for
them and the courts have ruled that be
difficult even with a will to keep your
children from their father and the event
of your death but if the courts have
ruled him to be you know ineligible and
I'm not an attorney but I mean I'm just
trying to think through this logically
with you then you would decide who's
going to take care of the kids if
something's gonna happen to you now I
cannot think of a case like none I can't
think of a scenario in which I would
leave him money your ex I would leave
money to the children in a trust that is
to be managed for the good of the
children and someone else is managing
the trust maybe your parents your sister
your brother I don't know but that's
managed for the good of the kids and
that can include and should probably
include some of the monies like if you
had a million dollar life insurance
policy on you you would pay that into
the trust for the good of the kids if
you were to die but your ex couldn't get
his hands on that because it's being
managed to spy someone else but income
off of that trust to support the
children should be going to him he
should be getting a check once a month
from that trust morally speaking to to
take care of your kids an assist in
caring for them can also put provisions
in the family trust to take care of your
kids when they turn 16 you could
them by a car in our case the way I was
written up we paid half of our kids cars
and meaning we matched we had 401 Dave
and so in a matching plan and when they
turned 16 we paid half of their first
car and so if they saved up 500 bucks
they got a thousand-dollar car and we
had that as a provision in the will that
the trust if Sharon and I died would do
the same thing now that Trust has long
since disbanded of course and will never
never occur because the kids are now
grown and they've have their own cars
and so forth and the next thing we said
was if something happened that they had
a major medical event and some of the
trust needed to pay out some extra
monies to take care of their health
needs you know if a child had a major
health issue then some of the trust
money could be used for that some of the
trust money could be used to pay for
college and then after college in our
case ours was set up to where they got
some of the money upon graduation they
got some more at 25 and some more 30 and
that would be all of that would have
happened if we had died while while our
children were minors that's just an
example of the kind of things you could
put in your will and this trust you can
make it do anything you want it to do
but it would be highly unusual for you
to allow your ex-husband to manage your
wealth for the good of your children if
you were that trusting of him you
probably wouldn't be getting a divorce
so I didn't think we're gonna go that
way so I put someone else to managing
the money and then you determine based
on the situation and eligibility legally
who's going to take care of the kids if
something happens to you and all of that
is in the will and as soon as the
divorce is finalized you need a new will
that's simple anytime there's a big life
change you get married you get divorced
you move States you know change in
wealth substantial change in wealth up
or down you need to relook at your will
and rethink about it we revisit and go
through ours every year it's a big hairy
deal we comb through it look at all the
different things we've got structured is
everything right we go over there with
the attorney we go over it with the
family we go over it with the leadership
team here at Ramsey so that if something
happens in the coming 12 months everyone
is
on what's gonna happen there are no
surprises you should always by the way
everyone needs a will you need to go to
mama bear legal forms calm and get your
will going everyone needs a will and it
doesn't take but about 20 minutes to
knock one out a basic will 100 bucks or
so will knock it out and it's just good
management of your life man and it's
really kind of a it's a an emotionally
strenuous exercise because you have to
actually sit around discuss you dying
and so I call it the Monty Python
meeting that we have once a year I'm
feeling much better it's only a flesh
wound you know I mean all that stuff
right and so because we're sitting there
talking about me dying the whole time
for this two-hour meeting and we go
through all these details of what's
gonna happen in the coming year if I die
and Sharon has figured it out that our
estate plan is predicated on me dying
first which makes me a little worried
like she has a plan or something so it's
so anyway yeah everyone needs a will